الاشتراكيه مثل اي مذهب فلسفي سياسي
اقتصادي يصعب تعريفه بكلمات جامعه مانعه
يتفق عليها الجميع وانما الاشتراكيه عندما
تذكر في اي مكان في العالم ينصرف الذهن
الى قضايا العداله الاجتماعيه
الاشتراكيون همهم الاساسي تطبيق نظم تحقق
اكبر قدر ممكن من العداله الاجتماعيه
والعداله والمساواه في توزيع الثروات
وطبعا في المشاركه في السلطه
الاشتراكيه بهذا المعنى موجوده في الغرب
وموجوده في الشرق ويمكن ان تطبق في النظم
الديمقراطيه والنظم غير الديمقراطيه وعلى
ارض الواقع في اوروبا الغربيه الراسماليه
الديمقراطيه هناك احزاب اشتراكيه عتيده
منذ عشرات السنوات
المستشار الجديد لالمانيا غلاف شولز على
سبيل المثال ينتمي الى حزب اشتراكي الرئيس
الفرنسي الاسبق فرانس كان ينتمي الى الحزب
الاشتراكي الفرنسي
حتى الولايات المتحده التي كانت كلمه
الاشتراكيه فيها سيئه السمعه مثل الشيوعيه
طوال فتره الحرب البارده فيها سياسيون
يفتخرون بانهم اشتراكيون وابرزهم طبعا
الذي كان مرشحا لرئاسه الولايات المتحده
لكن الاشتراكيه في العالم الغربي وفي
النظم الراسماليه عاده تعني مجموعه من
السياسات هدفها تحقيق العداله الاجتماعيه
يعني الحزب الاشتراكي عاده هيكون بيتبنى
سياسات ضريبيه تصاعديه مرتفعه على
الاغنياء يعني ياخذ من الاثرياء ضرائب
اكثر من غيرهم ماذا يفعل بهذه الضرائب
ينفقها على برامج اجتماعيه مثل التعليم
والرعايه الصحيه الى اخره اي ياخذ من
الاغنياء ويعطي للفقراء
عاده هذه الاحزاب او هذه الحكومات
بتميل الى ان تلعب الدوله دورا اكبر في
اداره الاقتصاد والهدف الاساسي حمايه
الضعفاء والفقراء والمهمشين الحكومات
اليمينيه تفضل ان تكون دور الحكومه محدود
وتترك لقواعد السوء مساحه اكبر في اداره
الاقتصاد
لكن الاشتراكيه في الصين ليست مجرد نظاما
هدفه الاساسي تحقيق المساواه بين طبقات
المجتمع الاشتراكيه في الصين مثل
الاشتراكيه في الاتحاد السوفيتي المنهار
هي مجرد مرحله انتقاليه هدفها تمهيد
الطريق لتطبيق الشيوعيه كيف ذلك هذا يحتاج
الى اطلاله سريعه او معرفه سريعه بافكار
الفيلسوف قرن ماركس اهم منظري الشيوعيه في
التاريخ
كارل ماركس اللي اتولد في المانيا
وتوفي في لندن 1883 واللي مرتبط في اذهان
الكثيرين في العالم العربي بصوره سلبيه
واحيانا شيطانيه كان يحلم بعالم مثالي
وكانت لديه افكار مركزيه اهم هذه الافكار
المركزيه ان تاريخ البشريه كله ليس الا
تاريخا للصراع بين الطبقات وحدد طبقتين
اساسيتين في صراع منذ فجر التاريخ طبقه
البرجوازيه وطبقه البروتاريا
البرجوازيه هي الطبقه التي تملك وتتحكم في
ادوات الانتاج وما هي ادوات الانتاج
المصنع المزرعه المزرعه المستشفى المدرسه
وما هي طبقه البرولوتاريا هي طبقه العمال
التي لا تملك ادوات الانتاج ولا تستطيع
التحكم فيها كل ما تملكه الجهد والوقت وهي
تبيع عملها مضطره
للبرجوازيه حتى تعيش
كارل ماركس كان يعتقد ان
الطاحتين الطبقتين في صراع حتمي طوال
الوقت وان هذا الصراع يعني موجود منذ فجر
التاريخ ولكنه ياخذ اشكالا مختلفه حسب
النظام الاقتصادي اللي موجود يعني انتقلت
البشريه من صراع العبيد في مواجهه الاسياد
لما كان النظام القائم على في الدول يعني
او على الارض هو نظام العبوديه ثم اصبح
الصراع بين اقنان الارض وبين ملاك الاراضي
ثم تحول هذا الصراع الى صراع بين العمال
واصحاب العمل كان في تقديره ان البشريه في
مرحله تطور مستمر وان هذا التطور يفضي
طوال الوقت الى نظام اقتصادي ارقى بدات
البشريه بالشيوعيه البدائيه يعني ايه
الشيوعيه البدائيه ما الانسان في البدايه
كانت الغابه والطرائد التي في الغابه
مشاعر للجميع اي انسان يستطيع ان يصطاد اي
حيوان او ياكل من حشائش الارض متاحه
للجميع ده كان بيسميها شيوعيه بدائيه
تطورت الى نظام ارقى وهي نظام العبوديه ثم
تطورت الى نظام ارقى وهي نظام
الاقطاع ثم تطور الاقطاع الى الراسماليه
هو كان تصوره ان الراسماليه لابد ان تتطور
الى نظام ارقى النظام الارقى هو الشيوعيه
وما هي الشيوعيه ولماذا الانتقال اليها
ضروره من وجهه نظر كارل ماركس الراسماليه
الهبت الصراعي الطبقي بشكل غير مسبوق في
التاريخ وهي اخذه الى زوال بثور الطبقه
البرولوتاريا التي يتم استغلالها على
البرجوازيه التي تستغلها وانتصار
البروليتاريا امر حتميا الشيوعيه كما
يتخيلها المركزيون نظام مثالي يعيش فيه
المجتمع وفي سلام تام لماذا يعيش في سلام
تام لانه مجتمع بلا طبقات اجتماعيه لا
برجوازيه ولا برولوتاريا
كيف يمكن ان يعيش مجتمع بلا طبقات
اجتماعيه بنزع الملكيه الفرديه التي راى
الماركسيون والشيوعيون انها اس البلاء اين
تذهب الملكيات التي يتم انتزاعها من
الافراد تصبح ملكيه عامه وتقسم ثروه هذا
المجتمع بالتساوي بين افراده او وفقا
للمقوله الشهيره من كل حسب قدرته الى كل
حسب حاجته واعتقد المرقسيون ان الانسان لا
يستطيع ان يصل الى الشيوعيه الا من خلال
مرحله انتقاليه في هذه المرحله الانتقاليه
التي سميت بالاشتراكيه تقوم حكومه او دوله
تؤمن بالشيوعيه بالاشراف على عمليه نقل
الملكيه من الافراد الى المجتمع ولما
تكتمل
وتكتمل النظام وتطبق الشيوعيه لن يكون
الانسان في حاجه الى حكومه اصلا وبهذا
المعنى الاشتراكيه ليست نظاما مختلفا عن
الشيوعيه ولكنها مرحله اكثر تطورا من
الراسماليه واقل رقيا من الشيوعيه وفقا
للمركزيين
هل هذا الكلام قابل للتطبيق اذكر كم ان
كارل ماركس وفلاسفه الشيوعيه كانوا فلاسفه
ينظرون يحلمون لكنهم لا يدخلون ابدا في
التفاصيل اتباع ماركس دخلوا في التفاصيل
من خلال تجارب سياسيه كثيره جدا وواجهه
صعوبات جامه في التطبيق وحاولوا التغلب
عليها بتصورات مختلفه للوصول الى الشيوعيه
اذكركم انه منذ انتهاء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وحتى سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي في
نهايه 91 كان ثلث العالم تقريبا يعيشوا
تحت نظم تقول انها شيوعيه
وحتى هذه اللحظه هناك خمس دول تعلن انها
شيوعيه الصين اشهرهم لكن هناك كوبا
وفيتنام وكوريا الشماليه وجمهوريه لاوس لم
نسمع ابدا صحيح عن تطبيق الشيوعيه كما
تصورها كارل ماركس ولكن كل الدول التي
قالت انها شيوعيه وتقول انها شيوعيه تعلن
انها تطبق اشكالا مختلفه من الاشتراكيه
معلنين ان املهم او هدفهم النهائي هو
تطبيق الشيوعيه